a lot of growth is happening in the
southeast part of the valley
smith's is going to be building a new
marketplace not too far from lake mead
and warm springs
and it'll be the anchor of a new
shopping center and also bring
hundreds of jobs with it madison
kimbrough visited that area to find out
what people have to say about it
she's live tonight with more
yes now residents in the cadence
neighborhood here in henderson
definitely had a lot to say about this
new park marketplace
a lot of people are excited about how
convenient it is others concerned that
it's going to bring a lot of congestion
to the area
love can't wait we've been waiting for
it we keep we kept hearing about it
it was coming it was coming and we'd
never thought it would we didn't think
it would happen but it finally did
it's happening after years of
preparation it looks like smith's food
and drug is set to launch its
multi-million dollar smith's marketplace
in the newly developed cadence
neighborhood of henderson this november
we heard it's going to be like
multi-level too so you can maybe dine in
there and again employs a lot of people
brings a lot of good people to the
neighborhood
the 31-acre development will be located
at warm springs road and lake mead
parkway
set to create 275 jobs the marketplace
will have a gas station
along with an apparel section houseware
decor
hardware and gardening area a one-stop
shop that will make shopping very
convenient for residents
i'm actually pretty excited in order for
us to go to the store we got to go like
we got to drive like
three miles away from our house and
right here we can pretty much
walk on the flip side though some
residents are worried about the amount
of people it will bring
for me personally i'm a little bit
worried about the traffic i think it's
great in one way another
is maybe not so great there's going to
be a lot of people here a lot of cars
a lot of traffic
now for those not interested in
strolling the aisles for food and
merchandise the store
will feature 40 000 different items for
people to shop online
and then go and pick up at the store
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now